e
it being about 10 o' we'll call the
finance committee to order for uh
executing 16
bills and we'll start with division one
bills and I'll recognize
representative Lehman to introduce the
bills I'll be just a second Mr chairman
the my vice chairman shared with me an
amendment that I hadn't seen yet so I
threw me a curve
so as we begin I'd like to recognize
that we have a new member here replacing
represent nor nordgren representative
priest is joining us as a new permanent
member and also welcome uh represent
Leon who's who's replacing maren Mooney
for for the sessions that Meen will miss
welcome both of you to
finance thank you Mr chairman so uh
first off we have House Bill 1
005 relative to judicial training he
understand that representative Maguire
has an amendment that will be passed
out yes thank you Mr chairman so um
you'll um Mr Hoffman is handing out
Amendment 1113 H and just I'll give you
some background while while he's doing
that um so this is a bill to um tell the
Judiciary to add a Jud a uh training
coordinator uh primarily for judges but
also for for others who work in the
Judiciary and and to create um
procedures for uh regular training uh
regular training for judges under the
direction of the chief justice so when
we heard this bill um first of all it it
was it it would would have acted in 60
days um and we originally thought well
just let them put this in in their um
next budget in a coordinated manner so
our original Amendment and the one that
we approved in committee 9 nothing was
to um have it take effect July 1st
2025 and it also because the Judiciary
basically said you're you're messing
with our internal um actions here and so
we we the bill had a lot of very a lot
of specific things about a judge will do
so many hours of training and such and
such a you know schedule and things like
that and so we cut that back to give
them a little more flexibility mostly
because it didn't have any concept that
a brand new judge needs more training
and a judge who's been there for 20
years needs less training right it was
it was strictly uh every judge every
year so much training so that didn't
seem to us to make a lot of sense so we
decided to give them more flexibility
okay um
so but the new amendment that was so but
we also have a several bills dealing
with bail and um one of the things in
common in all these other bills is that
the bail Commissioners need training
right so the bail Commissioners are
operating today and while we didn't hear
a lot of complaints about they made bad
decisions except in maybe one or two
isolated cases but it seems to be the
general General thought that they need
to be trained more professionally they
don't they don't just sort of jump in
and do their work so we thought subse so
subsequent to our actions on
105 I thought and and others seem to
agree is that this would be a good
vehicle for bail commissioner training
because bail Commissioners are are
nominally they're they're parts of the
Judiciary they're sort of the first
person from the Judiciary that an
accused person meets and so um so this
amendment uh
113h changes the effective date back to
60 days right so that's what it was in
the original bill so it makes it so the
the the coordinator is hired right away
and then it it puts training of bail
Commissioners into the purview of this
trainer of this uh training commissioner
right so it will help us with the other
bills by getting the the bail
Commissioners trained right away so I
would hope you would um approve this
amendment and so I will move Amendment
H okay so has everyone seen the
amendment do we need a roll call or can
we do this by show of hands I have a
question Mr
chairman represent Lehman thanks Mr
chairman I see there's some um numbers
in here as far as the amount of
time um blocks of time for
training is there an additional fiscal
impact to this Dan
or so I I believe this amendment is in
that in those
respects
um is um the same as the amendment we
passed in in committee N9 to nothing so
less there's there's sort of less detail
in here than was in the original Bill
the original Bill had you know 16 hours
of this and five hours of that and all
that sort of stuff this is much much
reduced it does say for for initial
train there's a Min minimum initial
training for
judges which is specified in the bill
right um orientation for new judges
education for new judges an hour of
training on each of these topics Etc but
it's very minimal um instruction all
that is copied from the original Bill we
left out um so many hours for clerks and
Court administrators and you know all
that other
stuff but it's still the bill still says
that those people will get appropriate
training so so our our my basic
philosophy with this is you know tell
them to to do training and if later it
seems to be that that they're not doing
enough then we can come back and have
more more
detail further
questions representative evil thank you
Mr chairman um I guess I had a question
I know that we're working on the other
bail reform bills and I wondered um
especially I guess this is addressed to
our division chair how this dovetails
with what's under
consideration in that and then the other
thing is I think the senate had passed a
bill to increase the hourly fee to 60
from 50 but this sticks with the
original
50 may I answer who wants the answer yes
so yeah so this bill
um it adds a little money in the sense
that it bail Commissioners will be paid
during their training so it requires
them to do eight hours of annual
training um and they will get uh pay of
$50 for those eight hours I mean that's
not very much money um and uh that's all
it does not this does not affect what
the bail Commissioners are paid for
their actual service right when they
when they meet with an accused and and
make a decision that's going to be in
another bill um but we anticipate what
the House pass passed and I guess we
anticipate passing is that that will be
$50 and then you know we can send it to
the Senate and see if you know make a
decision later about 50 versus
60 further questions I could add to that
so the division is working on House Bill
318 Senate Bill 249 and Senate bill and
looking at Senate Bill
252 uh tomorrow I'm bringing an
amendment forward to combine all those
I've been working with uh chairman Roy
talking to Chairman Roy and others about
trying to bring this together so we can
get something over the Finish Line in my
bill tomorrow there's an increase in the
bill commissioner fee to $60 in line
with the Senate which this bill has a
$50 or this amendment is a $50 amount so
we're trying to get everything on one
bill so it's uh easier to understand and
the fiscal note is consistent on each
bill instead of um inconsistent on all
the different bills which we've already
seen the division so I'm not sure where
I'm falling down on this amendment to be
candid Mr chairman but those are my
words representative grai um would it be
appropriate to send this back to the
division to get it merged in with the
with the rest of the
bills if if the amendment is not uh
adopted that might be the way to
go
or I could withdraw my motion and do
that yeah yeah okay so are we do we want
to withdraw the whole bill or we want to
vote on what what's been passed so far
out of
division yeah vote on the bill as it
came
to okay and and deal the and put the
bail stuff into the other Bill bail
bills he has that you'll be working on
in division one all right
so um so I don't think this quite Works
no I I would can we not act at this
point what if just end the confusion Mr
chairman we'll just pull this back one
Z5 and we'll deal with it tomorrow all
right thank no vote on 1,5 at this point
all right next
bill all right moving right along so
House Bill 1199 relative to the services
of the office of child advocate for
youth experience ing homelessness and
making an appropriation therefore like
to recognize representative Sweden thank
you Mr chairman I would move in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
second and you recognize for statement
thank you Mr chairman uh obviously I I
want to State for the committee that all
nine of us are concerned with
homelessness among youth but there were
a number of issues with the approach
that this bill was going to take I was
trying to identify unused arpa funds to
fund a new state employee position in
the office of the child advocate uh to
expand their scope of services Beyond
student uh children that are in the
system uh to homeless youth up to the
age of 25 years old uh in order to
coordinate uh resources to uh house
those youths uh instead of spending that
onetime money on one-time needs or to
expand bed services at homeless shelters
it was going to be using arpa funds are
directing to find arpa funds to add
another state employee that would then
have to be sustained with general fund
dollars in the future uh which is why I
would I would move why I moved in
expedient to legislate thank
you okay representative Sweeny moves in
expedient representative Maguire seconds
Is there further discussion
representative grassy and we had
discussion from the the state um and the
department division for child advocacy
one of the concerns that they had to the
children that this bill deals with are
children that are not in the system
these are children that are not in
foster care they're not in the judicial
system anywhere they're not they they've
never been identified as as children in
need and what this you know it it
affects tremendously lgbtq children who
have been basically thrown out of their
homes these kids have never been in
trouble before but they have no place to
live and what this does is it's small
money to um to advocate for these
children to leverage this position into
more resources to be able to provide
alternative housing for these children
uh it it's something that right now the
department cannot deal with they are not
statuto allowed to deal with these
children and this bill will change that
so that they can deal with those
children uh this is something that is
ongoing it's not just a one-year thing
uh it's certainly something that we need
to identify um uh to identify these
children and be able to provide services
to the children these are children who
are at a very high risk of sex
trafficking I mean we talk about sex
traffic on the floor of the house this
is someplace we can actually do
something about it and i' hope that we
could overturn this committee decision
here and send this to the floor as ought
to
pass further
discussion seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate the clerk will
call the role on that
motion thank you Mr
chairman
representative Earth
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative
Tracy
yes
emmer representative Griffin yes
representative uh Leon
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes
representative Sweeney
yes representative camell yes
representative papichi Muller yes
Representative walner
no representative Lehman
no representative Buco
no representative Ood
no representative Heath
no representative Murray no
representative evil
no Representative torki
no representative hien Phillips
no representative string
no representative grassy
no representative Priest No
representative wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 13 to 12 any
affirmative the botion passes
all right being 13 to 12 and this will
obviously go on the regular
calendar next next
bill and the report is from
representative Sweeney and we need that
before we leave today before we leave
this
room it will be a minority a Minority
Report thank you and we need that before
you leave today
moving on to the next Bill thank you Mr
chairman House Bill
1279 relative to payment by the state of
a portion of the retirement system
contributions of political
subdivision employers like to recognize
you Mr
chairman thank
you okay one of the most important jobs
of the legislature to pass a balanced
budget in order to accomplish this the
task this task all expenditures must be
limited to a given amount supported by
expected Revenue the idea of the state
paying for municipal and County
Employees Retirement share leaves too
much uncertainty in the 24 months after
the budget is approved the state has no
control over how many new employees are
hired or any pay raises granted to them
this legislation Echoes a bill from last
year with the same title of property tax
reduction it would not accomplished the
claim of that title in 2023 the budget
sent back $100 million of direct
property tax reduction in reduced swept
payments a request of any group asking
how did that reduction work out is
answered with the answer I never saw one
this proposal would possibly reduce
those taxes by 28 million there would be
even less notice of such a reduction the
amount of work this proposed entails
proposal entails at all the
administrative levels is not worth all
the fuss over such a minor effort
in 2012 we stopped contributing to the
employer share of the retirement system
for non-state employees the difference
for that contribution was largely made
up by increases in the employee share
which was far less than the employer
share at the time those payments would
have cost the state 60 million now they
would be over 100
million I would move inexpedient to
legislate second and I'd like to
speak okay yeah okay um so to me the the
what you just heard was the blurb I
think for for the calendar um all right
but to me it's it's the the steps we got
here so this bill is identical to last
year's house bill 50 and if you remember
house bill 50 so did this pay 7 and a
half% of of U municipalities retirement
costs um uh I believe not teachers right
this is just um others but
um but uh we as a group um put it in the
budget well first of all we passed it on
the floor with a a very different
Amendment so the amendment changed it
from a from this ongoing 7 and a half%
which is roughly but but we we changed
it to an an immediate pay down of the
unfunded
liability of $50 million so onetime
roughly the same amount right so $50
million onetime pay down of the
liability that helps
municipalities and school districts and
others by reducing their ongoing costs
for retirement not as much as this this
shot would be for the specifics but long
term right sort of over the over the
long term and um so that's what we did
we we passed it in the house we put it
into the budget the Senate took it out
and then this year we did the same thing
we passed it in the house as House Bill
436 and I've already testified in the
Senate finance committee on exactly that
on the $50 million pay down of the
unfunded liability they did not
immediately itl it so I'm hoping it has
some chances over there um but
essentially my point is the reason this
should be itl is that we've already
considered this to death it's the same
thing as we did last year we did this
year it you know let's do it again next
year I guess or something but not now
further discussion on the amendment
representative
grassy um yes sir um Mr chairman one of
the things that this bill uh does is is
that this is a bill that we've seen yes
year after year is because our city
councils our Board of alderman our
Selectmen um our local governing
agencies have requested that we put this
bill in every year um when this was when
the retirement fund was originally
instituted the state said that they
would pay a share of the municipality's
cost in order to get them into the
system that promise has been degraded
every year since and in 2012 it was
significantly removed and what since
that time I served on the council that
time we saw a tax increase an immediate
tax increase because of that and the
thing is since that time communities
have been asking that we that we put
some of that support back into the
system the 7 half% is a small ask from
the communities but it's something that
the thing is is that will bring
stability to some local budgets and they
have requested it year after year and
they will continue to request it until
this legisl take Jackson to honor the
promise that was made to them when they
entered the retirement system and I
would urge the uh the committee to uh to
approve this uh U to approve this
bill representative papich Miller thank
you Mr chair just a couple of things uh
first um as somebody who's been the
finance director for the town of wiam I
do know that the legislature cannot make
promises for future legislators they can
only speak to their intent and keep
their word while they're in office when
a new term starts a new term starts and
realities change second on General
government accountability grounds
here the level of government that's
responsible for driving the cost by
making the decisions to hire people and
offer them benefits should be the level
of government that should address those
costs they are the ones hiring and they
are the ones who should pay for the
benefits when we separate the people who
benefit from the people who pay we end
up with less than optimal behaviors and
I'm trying to be very polite here so I
would suggest that this bill uh should
uh not see the light of day thank
you further
discussion seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate the clerk will
call the
role thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative
Lon uh representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Camal yes representative
Popovich Muller
yes Representative walner
no representative leishman
yes Representative vuko
no representative
uitt
yes represent of Heath
no representative Murray no
representative eel no Representative
tersi
no representative haken Phillips
no represent Stringham
yes represent grassy
no representative
Priest
No representative wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 16 to9 in
favor of the motion itl is adopted and
it will go in the regular
calar it's in the
full is your monity report is there a
Minority
Report yeah who will be the author yes
okay represent
grass
and the next
one thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1307 providing a supplemental
appropriation for members of the
retirement system receiving an
accidental disability retirement
allowance I'd like to call on
representative Maguire I'll I'll move
out to
pass thank you I'm sorry I I I didn't
hear that about to pass was a second a
second represent Sweeny all right
so um this bill um corrects an oversight
from I'm not sure if it's two or three
years ago but in the last session there
was a one-time uh $500 payment to
retirees um who had worked 20 years or
more as a as a supplement kind of
a it's not quite a cola but it's a
similar
and
um the the oversight in that payment was
that there are some retirees who retire
with
disability they retire when they get
their disability and they don't
necessarily make it to 20 years right
but but it it almost everyone involved
in this uh decision thinks that they
deserve this $500 payment so this bill
is a $500 payment for those who retire
due to disability and it comes to
there's there's like 802 such people
comes to $400,000 onetime payment and um
it is possible that that some employees
will receive this payment twice in the
sense that they did retire after 20
years with a dis Disability Pension but
that's felt to be sort of di Minimus so
um thank
you further
discussion seeing
none represento question for someone on
division one was there any discussion of
those individuals who um were disabled
who then took secondary employment
either locally or with the state
government
no
further
discussion seeing none the Motions ought
to pass on House Bill
1307 clerk will call a rooll thank you
Mr chairman representative Earth
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Leon yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
Popovich Muller
yes representative walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative buo yes representative
uitt
yes representative Heath
yes representative Murray
yes representative a
yes represent torski yes representative
hen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
priest yes representative wer yes Mr
chairman the vote is 24 to zero in the
affirmative motion passes so we had 25
of
us
all right let me recheck
here all right you're correct all
right 25 to zero the motion is ought to
pass it will go on the regular
calendar moving on to
1323 it was two it was
214s thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1323 making an appropriation for for the
printing costs of the New Hampshire
state
constitution like to recognize the
chairman Mr chairman thank
you every two years the Secretary of
State contracts to have 5,000 copies of
the New Hampshire Constitution printed
copy of 6 by9 in and has pictures of the
elected leaders so it is only current
for a two-year term the distribution is
mainly for the fourth graders who Tour
the State House as part of their
education the General Distribution is
somewhat limited the size is not as
convenient as most of the United States
contrib constitutions that different
groups distribute the majority of those
us Constitutions are 3 in by six and a
half and easily fit in a pocket this
bill proposes to print a large number of
that smaller size and make them more
generally available without expiration
because we wouldn't be having any
pictures of people in there we' just
have the the wording of the Constitution
by leaving out the elected elected
pictures the effective date will be
after the results of the next election
in order to include any Constitutional
Amendments that might pass in that
election we hope the size and lack of
pictures will reduce the cost which we
would told it would as well as making it
hand you to carry all of our citizens
should be familiar with this document
not just legislators and fourth graders
move on to
pass um Mr chairman I'd like to move um
Amendment 09 09h which you have in front
of you and it was the amendment that the
division passed
okay Amendment 09
09h and representative Maguire is
recognized to explain it yes so
um this amendment does a couple of
different things it moves the effective
date to uh July 1st 2025 so the
Secretary of State can put the printing
costs into his next budget we anticipate
that the constitution might
change um in November because we passed
that um Constitutional Amendment about
slavery and so it seems likely that that
would pass and the Constitution would
change so so if we printed this now it
would become obsolete quite quickly so
um that's why the delay and then also uh
the amendment allows if if people want
you know a a case of constitutions for
for handing out to groups or something
it allows the Secretary of State to
charge them a uh a fee for for that
printing so you know he'll still um hand
them out to visitors with no charge but
but if somebody wants a hundred of them
or something he he'll charge some costs
so that's what this amendment does is
there a second to the amendment
Sweeny okay any further discussion on
the proposed amendment 0909
seeing none can we do this by a show of
hands all in favor raise your
hand any
opposed the motion is adopt the
amendment is
adopted the motion is ought to pass as
amended is there any further discussion
on that
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the role on the motion to ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 1323
three thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri vs yes
representative Emer
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Lon yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative cambrell yes
representative po merer yes
representative walner
yes representative Lehman
yes representative buo
yes representative huitt
yes represent Heath
yes represent Murray
yes repres evil
yes repr schori yes
represent Heen Phillips
yes represent Stringham
yes representative
grassy representative
priest yes representative wer
yes Mr chairman would you believe the
vote is 25 to Z in the affirmative I
would believe that but put that on the
regular
calendar verb has been written in the by
me
yes second by
Sweeny okay moving on to the next bill
represent lean okay thank you Mr
chairman House Bill 1355 relative to the
New Hampshire National Guard Recruitment
and reinlist reenlistment incentive
program like to recognize representative
Sweeny thank you chairman I would move a
to pass and like to speak to my motion
second uh this bill is very simple it
would allow the New Hampshire National
Guard to offer up to $6,000 in a
reenlistment bonus to those members that
are not eligible for federal
reenlistment bonuses that they have
available the total fiscal note only
estimates up to
$50,000 being utilized for this effort
to help with uh retention and obviously
with recruitment but this is
specifically for reenlistment bonuses uh
the committee did not uh have a thorough
conversation on it as we are generally
supportive of efforts for the National
Guard to to
reinlist thank you thank you further
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill
1355 that
sweetie who was a second
Maguire okay seeing no further
discussion the clerk will call the rooll
on the motion of ought to pass on House
Bill
1355 thank you Mr chairman represent
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri vots yes
representative Emer
yes representative Griffin yes
representative
Lon representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
represent cell yes represent Popich
Muller yes represent waler
yes representative Lehman yes
representative bule yes representative
you yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil
yes represent chori
yes repres hen Phillips yes represent
Stringham yes represent grassie
yes represent priest yes represent
Wilder yes Mr chairman the vote is 25 to
Z in the affirmative motion passes it
will go on the regular
calendar and representative Sweeney has
the
blur moving on representative lean is
recognized for the next
Bill thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1394 relative to licens your regulation
of Music therapists and making an
appropriation therefore like to rep uh
recognize representative Maguire to
speak also to an amendment and thank you
Mr chairman if we need to start with a
with a motion maybe representative cells
would like
to yes thank you Mr chair um I'd like to
make a motion to
otpa okay representative um campell's
moves out to pass is there a
second second by representative Irv so
I'll move Amendment 1141 leash just a
second thank you I'm sorry I I'll move
Amendment 1141 H uh which actually has
representative Lehman's name at the top
but it is the amendment that we passed
in our
division um so this is a bill to uh
regulate music
therapists and um there are roughly 30
of them in the state the um office of
professional professional life
licenser uh plans to uh charge them a
licensing fee of roughly
$150 every two years the bill as it came
to us in included a new employee for the
oplc and so that's not justified by you
know 30 time 150 divided by two that
kind of thing so so this amendment um
changes the new employee to to a simple
$33,000 a year of additional temporary
part-time or overtime that to in their
budget which is which is is more or less
covered by the by the licensing
fees further discussion on the
amendment and who was the second on the
amendment clerk wants to
know lean's a second yeah further
discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question on the amendment
4111 all in favor raise your
hands hands down any
opposed motion is
adopted representative Maguire moves
ought to pass as amended and represent
representative cell representative
camell all right we'll move that up to
the other and the amendment is 114 1
H further discussion on 1394 as amended
by Amendment
4111 So yeah thank you Mr chair hole go
ahead uh may I so I'm I'm going to be
voting against this just to possibly
avoid the spectacle of a Maguire versus
Maguire for floor
fight but you you are welcome to vote as
you please thank
you hle thank you Mr share I understand
the desire of those pushing for the bill
to allow um this discipline to have
access to insurance money um I think the
free market solves some of these I know
that when we sought medical care for one
of our kids that wasn't covered by
insurance that wasn't covered by
anything else it was important enough
for us to get that treatment that we
dove into our checking account I think
just because we create access to
insurance doesn't mean we need to to
prohibit the growth of this by adding
one more license and more oversight by
government I will be voting against
it any further
discussion seeing none the clerical call
a rooll on the motion of ought to pass
as amended Amendment
4111 on House Bill
1394 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth
no represent McGuire
no represented Petri votes now
oh I'm sorry I didn't hear you vote yeah
no
okay uh representative Emer
no representative Griffin
no representative uh Leon
no representative Edwards no
representative Bean
no Representative hle
no representative Sweeny
yes oh I'm sorry I didn't hear okay I
just want to make sure first one
I'm representative camell
yes representative papovich Muller
no represent walner yes
representative Lehman
yes representative buo yes
representative you yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray
yes representative evil yes I'm
sorry yes thank
you represent torski
yes representative haen Phillips
yes representative string
yes represent grassy
yes representative priest
yes representative wer
yes Mr chairman a vote is 15 to10 in
affirmative the motion passes motion
passes 15 to10 it will go on the regular
calendar
cber uh is it going to be a minor
report all right is it is there one yeah
we'll
okay okay 15 to1 Minority Report
forthcoming who's going to write that is
that we don't know yet don't we have to
have that decision before we leave here
yes and we have to have the blur
according to what the speaker sets we
can copy the one from last time whatever
works M Mr chair do I need to do a
majority report or do we have uh the
blurb is it
written all right no it
has again we can look in the last time
there's no yeah
okay very good got that nailed down all
right represent
leash thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1465 relative to studies of nuclear
energy Technologies and renaming the
office of offshore wind industry
development like to recognize
representative sweede thank you Mr
chairman I move a to pass on House Bill
1465 is there a second Griffin
representative Griffin
seconds House Bill 1465 is motion is
ought to pass representa Sweeney is
recognized thank you Mr chairman the the
title does really sum up what this bill
largely does um it just directs the uh
new direct uh Department of energy to
coordinate all studies relating to
nuclear energy renames the office was
pretty straightforward bill with with no
thorough discussion or opposition in the
committee in the
division thank
you any further discussion on the motion
of ought to pass on House Bill
seeing none are you ready for the
question public will call the rooll on
the motion of ought to pass House Bill
1465 by representative Sweeny seconded
by representative
Griffin thank you Mr
chairman representative F yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emerich yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Lyon
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
papovich merer yes representative
walner yes representative leechman yes
representative buo
yes representative HT yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
torski yes represent hen Phillips yes
representative
Stringham yes representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Zer
in favor of the motion motion being 25
to Z is
adopted was there a was there Mone in
this bill does anybody
remember there is from the agency but
there are no General funds
Mr okay no General funds in it guess we
can put this on the consent
calendar Mi Mr
chair represent hle on HB
1323 in that the effective date is the
next f calendar or the next fiscal
budget can that also go on consent well
to be consistent it spends money even
though it's it's put off okay there is
money involved so someone might object
if it isn't and hopefully it'll be a
quick
vote especially if no one signs up to
vote it to to
U
debate it
okay represent
lean thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1647 relative to the calculation of
group to retirement benefits in the
retirement
system and representative Maguire would
like to speak to the amendment which you
should have in front of you which is
1134 um yes thank you I'll move
Amendment
1134 so
um just just to set the stage so uh this
is a very important bill and and it was
very heavily supported by the house uh
in its original form last year which was
House Bill
436 so it was a bill to improve the
retirement um circumstances of group two
members that's police fire and
Corrections
and um because they had been uh it
originally started as strictly for those
who were hired as of
2010 but not yet vested right because in
2010 we made significant changes to the
retirement system both in the
multiplier and the way that that income
was calculated and and the um some of
the dates by which you know the the
length of service required to get
retirement things like that so there
were significant changes in
2010 maybe 2011 and 2011 really and um
so that's been brewing and now um this
bill the original House Bill
4036 undid all of those changes for all
of those affected employees not for
employees younger than that not not for
those who weren't yet hired in
2011 all right um House Bill 436 would
have cost $250 million spread over five
years it was passed strongly by the
house we put it in the budget the Senate
took it out of the budget um and the
Senate substituted a commission to study
the whole issue the commission met this
summer it was chaired by representative
Maguire not
me and um they voted 8 to six in favor
of uh improving just the multiplier of
those implo of but but for all group two
employees who are not yet retired not
just the ones hired prior to 2011 so um
it change so what that's what this bill
does does is it changes the
multiplier um from uh the current 2% to
25% times length of service times um
times average final
compensation and um so the total cost of
this for existing employees and
regardless of whether those employees
are state employees most of them are
Municipal Employees is $53 million
roughly
and um so this amendment is just sort of
a technical change to the bill because
the bill didn't include the
appropriation so this is the
appropriation um for that $53 million
that's what the amendment is um but it
it this is not a a substantive change to
the bill it's it's um just makes it
correct basically from a financial point
of view now um there is this bill does
create ongoing costs to municipalities
and the state in the sense that
employees who are not in group two who
are not yet employees people who are not
yet hired well they're going to have a
better pension ongoing than current law
and therefore they'll be slightly more
expensive so so that cost is I believe
it's roughly um you you have a fiscal
note here but it's it's a little under 4
million a year for the subdivision for
and and a little under a million a year
for the state but you know it pays for
something which is a better um pension
and the 2 and a half% is standard in
this um occupation for our surrounding
states from Massachusetts Maine and
Vermont and so therefore we have had a
very hard time hiring uh group to
employees and this will go a long way to
to improving that situation speaking of
which I I did not arrange
that timing was great
though all right seconded by
representative Griffin who's going to
write the blur representative
Griffin all right and be sure and
mention what the amendment
does all right so we have an amendment
to adopt
um Amendment 1134 to House Bill
1647 is there any further discussion on
the
amendment can we vote for this by a show
of
hands all in favor raise your
hands hands down anyone opposed the
motion for the amendment 1134 is
adopted the amendment now the motion
before us now is
1647 as a amended by 1134 ought to pass
further discussion representative
Griffin I'll move ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill
1647 FN a and I show a second by
Sweeny this bill addresses the
inequities that resulted from changes
made in the retirement system in
2011 it was recommended by the
retirement Comm miss that me last year
it came out of the policy committee with
a 20 vote and easily pass the Full House
Bill increases group two retirement
annuity multiples to
2.5% for each year of service Beyond 10
years for members who commence service
prior to July 1
2011 but had not attained vested status
prior to January 1
2012 and for members who commence
service on or after July 1
2011 including future hires this change
only applies to members qualifying
retirement provided under RSA
100a uh semicolon 5 Roman numeral 2 or
for disability retirement on RSA one
100-
A6 Roman numeral 2 the finance committee
amended the money included in the bill
from
55,000 55 m600 th000 to 53 million
600,000 based on updated calculations
made by the retirement
system thank
you further
discussion seeing none are you ready for
the question the motion is ought to pass
as amended by 1134 on House Bill 1647
the clerk will call a rooll on the
motion of ought to pass as amended thank
you Mr chairman representative Earth
no representative McGuire
yes representative Petri
votes
yes representative em yes representative
Griffin
yes representative Leon yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes Representative
hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative cell
yes representative Popovich merer
yes representative walner
yes representative Le
yes represent buo yes representative U
yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes represent toori
yes represent haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
priest
yes
representative uh Wier
to2 Mr chairman the vote is 23-2 any
affirmative 23-2 the motion passes and
it will go on the regular
calendar and it will there be a Minority
Report no
no author Le of author Griffin second
Sweeny and no no Minority Report correct
no Minority
Report okay representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman just before
we jump to 1678 I'd like to thank the
division for their work we had a very
busy last couple weeks we have a very
busy day tomorrow on cannabis and bail
reform but just a thank you going out
there for all your help so House Bill
1678 establishing a New Hampshire Farm
to school local food incentive pilot
program like their recognized
representative
grassy move out to pass
second representative grassy moves out
to pass representative Hugh at seconds
further
discussion seeing none who who was a
second Gra
um I can you would represent Maguire
yeah so I'm I'm opposed to this bill um
it what it it's basically um a
straightforward subsidy for of two years
if I remember correctly roughly it costs
roughly
$120,000 a year um for uh New Hampshire
farmers of specific products that
mentioned in the bill Maple and other
things and um so it creates a program
where schools can can apply for for this
money and then uh use it in their in
their C spend the money with New
Hampshire farmers and then um use the
products in their cafeterias and so on
and um it just seems like a a lot of
money for for a very little benefit
because part of the bill I believe hires
someone to run the program right so
um or at least a part-time someone to
run the program so and there's
applications there's this there's that
so so the actual benefit being
um uh realized is fairly is small
compared to to the expense so I'm I'm
going to be voting against this was the
employee at the at agriculture or at
education I think it's at I believe it's
at agriculture I don't have the bill in
front of me unfortunately it's an
agriculture um
to to you know accept the applications
hand out the money Etc very good further
discussion on the motion representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I I just
wanted to say that um I I've been in
previous terms committees where a bill
extremely similar to this has been
debated and I've always come down on uh
no uh because I think we have a a market
based economy that can make this happen
it's just a money issue and I don't I
don't think we should be uh
incentivizing any dependency on a state
program the farmers can Market their
products the schools can buy their
products and with the with the addition
of a $40,000 person this is just a
tremendous amount of overhead so this is
actually a very easy not for
me representative Heath thank you Mr
chair um I'd like to speak in support of
this bill we've seen it numerous times
our Farmers work well with our school
districts this is an opportunity to have
a person work with our schools to bring
the um food that comes from the farmers
um we've see the wonderful work that
they're doing with the farmers markets
across the state this will when my
grandchildren and I love to work in the
garden
most kids like to work with in the
garden this gives an opportunity for
someone to work with the schools to
maybe even start one of their own
Gardens I think this is a great
opportunity and I definitely will be
voting yes on the OTP thank you very
much further discussion representative
Griffin yes I'd like to point out that
uh the fiscal committee dealt with a
bill some time ago that involved a half
a million dollars of government money
and it went to the same virtually the
same
purpose uh the problem with this bill is
that the state money instead of going to
the end use goes
primarily to personnel and
benefits and uh I think a half a million
dollars of the government money should
go a long way to solving the problem and
I don't think the state needs to get
involved in
this thank
you pres tki thank you Mr
chairman um I'd like to speak in support
of this bill um the price tag is
relatively small for something that's
going to have a big impact and be a win
for Farmers a win for our small
producers a win for our schools and a
win for our school children here in the
state part of the bill um is an
educational portion that will bring uh
programming to our school children to
understand where their food comes from
how it's grown this is more than just
paying Farmers for food for cafeterias
and I would encourage the committee to
please support the opop
pass further discussion representative
grassy yes uh Mr chairman I speak in in
support of this as well and I I just
wanted to correct some information here
the bill in no way says that there will
be a new person hired in any departments
it says that the department May contract
with New Hampshire Farm to school to
support the program coordination
management which New Hampshire Farm the
school is already doing most of that
work so uh this provides an opportunity
for Farmers as been said to bring
product into the schools uh and
particularly in smaller school districts
that don't have the ability to do a lot
of this stuff themselves I think a lot
of towns will benefit from this more
than the bigger cities will
benefit further
discussion seeing none are you ready for
the question the Motions ought to pass
on House Bill 1678 the clerk will call a
rooll on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth
no representative McGuire no
representative Petri votes
no representative Emer no representative
Griffin
no representative Leon no representative
Edwards no representative Bean
no Representative hle
no representative Sweeney no represent
camell no representative pich Muller
no representa walner yes representative
Lehman
yes representative buo yes
representative U yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes represent sori
yes represent haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent grassy
yes representative priest yes
representative wer
no Mr chairman the vote is 12 to 13 the
motion
fails okay will there be a Minority
Report I think we need a new motion Mr
chairman we need a motion yes we need a
new
motion uh Mr chairman I'll move itl all
right wi moves
itl second by
Sweeney further
discussion seeing none cler will call a
rooll on the motion of inexpedient to
legislature thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes this
is
I okay Maguire yes representative
Maguire representative pet votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney uh I'm
sorry Leon yes representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
representative
hle
yes representative uh Sweeney yes
represent camell yes representative
papovich meller yes Representative
walner
no representative Lehman
no Representative buo no Representative
huitt no representative Heath no
representative Murray no representative
evil no Representative tki no
representative haaken Phillips no
represent Stringham no representer
grassy no representa priest
no representative Wier yes Mr chair the
vote is 13 to 12 in favor of the
motion
okay and will the representative Maguire
will write the report and on is there a
Minority
Report who who will write it
rashley
okay
okay thank you division
one there the bulk of our bills now
we'll move on to division
two and recognize representative
Emer thank you Mr
chairman first bills HB 1032
FN relative to certificate of title
exemptions for vehicles 20 or more years
old and I look for a motion from repres
resentative Pap
mu thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion of OTP and briefly speak to my
motion you recognize to speak I'll
second
it thank you Mr Speaker this is a tiny
change in the law that shifts from um
the year 2000 that was in a previous
statute to a rolling period of 20 years
for vehicles that do not require
certificates of title anymore
straightforward voice voted con you know
unanimous consent type Bill except it
was a finance bill noos in committee I
don't want to spend a lot of time on
it okay further discussion the motion is
ought to pass on House Bill
1032 is there any further
discussion pres hacken Phillips thank
you Mr chair I just wanted to mention
that in our subdivision um you know we
agreed that this was a budget neutral
type um Bill and that you know given
that fact that the group was in
agreement unanimously to pass this Bill
thank you further
discussion seeing none motion is ought
to pass on House Bill
1032 there's no further discussion the
clerk will call the role on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative F yes representative
Maguire yes yes representative Petri
votes yes representative emmer yes
representative
Griffin representative Lyon yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
Popovich Muller
yes representative Walmer
yes representative leechman yes
representative buo
yes representative uitt
yes representative Heath yes represent
Murray yes represent Vil
yes representative torki yes represent
haen Phillips yes represent Stringham
yes represent grassy
yes represent priest yes represent wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to zero in
affirmative okay motion is 25 to zero
and is was there any money in this bill
does anybody
remember I think it's Revenue neutral
all right let's try the regular calendar
and see if that'll that'll work regular
or consent consent you want to go
consent consent yeah let's try
consent uh will be
patri what that you're the author of the
blur I am for that one
yeah all right is there someone
else who made the
motion that was papich Muller oh papichi
Muller okay I'll have the report you
will have the report thank you very much
good job I want to get out of that
one okay that motion is adopted moving
next to uh
representative Emer for the next bill
House Bill 1288 relative to establishing
certain due process rights for students
student organizations and faculty
members facing disciplinary actions by
state institutions of Higher
Learning I would look to the chairman
for a
motion I move on to pass
second would you like to speak to
your I believe you have some remarks I I
do
I'd also ask representative Popich
Miller he did a excellent job this
morning would you make the same comment
you did this morning you were on a
roll
well that's uh Hy lots of pressure here
I'm afraid so to make a long story short
as much as I'm capable of
that the essence of the bill is to
establish certain due process rights for
campus community members that are facing
disciplinary reaction in you know our
public colleges and
universities we've received testimony
that uh most of such situations would
not escalate to the point where
suspensions may be at risk and I would
strongly suggest that for
those infrequent cases where there is a
disputed proceeding where you know the
party being accused feel strong in the
arena and they should have those process
due process rights secure to them so
they can defend themselves against an
accusation that they find is unjust it
is a complicated area of the law that
are interplays with Federal legislation
and so on but this bill has been uh you
know thought very thoroughly and uh it's
a good
bill there was also testimony on the
size of the uh fiscal note and I think
that it's important to notice that if
providing du process to the students and
other campus community members that are
facing suspension is rather expensive
that's a sign of the fact that
frequently we accuse them and we don't
give them their due process rights and
therefore we risk reaching the incorrect
conclusion and you know it's it's
important to support this Bill thank you
further discussion represent I have a
couple of comments representative Emer
first uh
we also we had testimony in in the
committee from a representative from the
University system that said last year
they had approximately 20,000 or plus
issu issues or incidents or cases or
what whatever we're calling them and of
those 80 actually went to a hearing so
the the drop off of uh pleading out or
whatever whatever you might want to call
it is very high um and so
but the what we're trying to avoid is a
kangaroo court where somebody shows up
to for a hearing and they're declared
guilty before they they even show up so
what this does is it gives them rights
so that the the hearings are not are not
kangaroo courts thank you representative
Heath thank you Mr chair um I would like
to speak against this bill the
university system has a long standing
disciplinary system that immediately
addresses
situations um that is particularly in
compliance with Federal statutes this
bill creates unnecessary costs for
families and the university system
Federal Law requires
immediate steps to address
situations um the sponsor could not
really talk to any specific data or
instances that this this bill would
address this creates a parallel system
within our University system the
university system spoke against this
bill this conflicts with our federal
highered statutes and I would recommend
an itl motion on this bill I will not
support the art to pass thank you very
much further discussion representative
H thank you Mr chair if I recall
correctly this was a bill that there was
a great discussion on the floor relative
to due process
and we would want it seems to me that we
would want our campuses to truly be a
place where Free Speech can happen and
it is not necessarily guided and
constrained by the con by the the
management and the and the upper
leadership of the university and becomes
an echo box what we really want to do is
allow policies that let the students
share the information they want as they
continue in their education I will be
supporting the
aass
represent hacken
Phillips oh thank you Mr chair um I I
too will be voting Against The Spill um
for a few specific reasons um that
representative Heath already touched
upon but I just wanted to delineate a
little further um in our subcommittee we
heard no testimony that there was any
example of any student or faculty member
who had been denied their due process
rights in a result of a disciplinary
hearing and either the community colle
colge system or the university system um
and when um both the sponsors and other
folks giving testimony were asked you
know had they experienced any you
know EV had they come upon any evidence
of the reason for this bill being
necessary the only person who offered
any um support was someone saying that
they were trying to model um other
states um who had passed similar
legislation um to defeat I quote
wokness unquote so um again there was no
evidence that this was needed um
furthermore um if if in case you know if
in fact someone had been denied due
process in either one of those systems
you know they are still afforded the
opportunity to seek damages and Justice
through our court system so I fail to
understand why we would expand the
government's footprint EXP spend
additional costs for an additional quasi
Judicial System Within These systems as
opposed to just using the system in
place that is already
working furthermore um both the
Community College systems of New
Hampshire and the University Systems in
New Hampshire testified that there were
no Appropriations to assist them in
supporting this new infrastructure to
guarantee these due process rights that
again were not evidenced for any need so
you know there this bill is creating
quite the snowball of infrastructure for
our state without giving an adequate
support to fund it to run it to to
operationalize it so um you know I'm
having a lot
of trouble trying to find out you know
to make sense of this in my mind of why
it's needed and why it's appropriate to
pass lastly I'll just say that I am very
concerned about the conflict of federal
law that will be will be a problem if
this bill is passed because we're not
just talking about you know future
litigation coming down the road from
possible students or faculty who are
denied certain rights but we're also
talking about federal funds coming to
our states to support these University
and Community College systems if this
bill goes into effect so this I think
the testimony uncovered
in our subdivision hearing shows
substantial negative and adverse effects
if this bill were to go into effect and
when in fact on the opposite end there
was no evidence or substantial testimony
to show us that this bill is worthwhile
for our state and for that reason for
all of these reasons Mr chair I will not
be supporting this
bill representative Edwards uh thank
thank you Mr chair um I I I think there
are reports all over the country where D
process rights of college students have
been uh impinged and um given that our
public schools are uh our government
this isn't an issue of having government
get involved our public school system at
the University and college level or
already government and as such they are
obligated to be protecting fully the
Bill of Rights of every student and the
right to do process is uh is Central to
every every human right in terms of
protecting us from an intrusive abusive
government and and so it's given that
it's an inherent uh and necessary and
important duty I'm I'm going to be
voting for this because uh I I don't
think they should be opposed to it
because it's their obligation
anyways further
discussion representative Emme yes the
argument about how much this is going to
increase cost is kind of like a catch22
discussion because if it's if it's going
to increase cost that's saying they're
not doing anything
now I mean so they've got to have some
cost at in the current program whatever
they're using I I don't I don't see
where the increased cost comes from
I thank you further
discussion seeing none the motion on
House Bill 1288 is ought to
pass if there's no further discussion
the clerk will call the rooll on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative am yes representative
Griffin yes representative uh
Leon representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell
yes representative papichi meller
yes Representative walner no
Representative leean
no Representative buo no representative
U
no representative Heath
no representative Murray no
representative evil no
Representative torki no representative
haen Phillips
no representative Stringham no represent
grassy
no representative Priest No
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 13 to 12 in favor of the
motion motion of a to pass is
adopted representative Lynn if I put in
names who's going to speak on this may I
put you as the first
speaker thank
you and the the
uh the motion was by representative
papichi seconded by Rec representative
Emer it was all right how do you want it
wer you want Emer papichi all right
motion by Emer seconded by papovich
okay I think Emer has the
report yes there will be a Minority
Report Mary hecken Phillips will write
it all right
minority and who's going to write that
hacken
Phillips okay moving on to House Bill
1304 representative
emmer House Bill 1304 FN local relative
to vessel Reg registration and boat fee
decals I don't think this is going to be
a contentious one I
recognize representative papichi mu for
a motion know thank you I would like to
make a motion to adopt the um amendment
number
0933 H for HB
1304 you may speak to motion yeah U very
briefly it's uh Common Sense amendment
that we adopted uh in with that we
recommended from Finance 2 with 90 there
is a minor wording change where the
original Bill said it applied only to
renew decals but we also it's good
policy to also apply to replace decals
to decals it doesn't change anything in
else in the bill it doesn't change the
fiscal note so it's just housekeeping
really so it is there is an amendment on
this bill then right yes this is the
motion we are discussing is for the
amendment on the bill very good okay
what's represent Heath seconds the the
amendment what's the amendment Amendment
0933 Mr
chair representative hack Phil thank you
Mr chair I just wanted to let the uh
larger committee know that the amendment
actually originates in the gel car
committee which I help serve on and um
this is part of um
concern that
arose that there were fees being
possibly charged for replacement decals
um that were not explicitly authorized
in law so this minor change just helps
reaffirm that Authority thank you thank
you further discussion on Amendment
0933 seeing none I'd like to adopt this
by the show of hands if if that's
agreeable all in favor raise your hands
hands down any opposition seeing none
the motion is adopted for the amendment
0933 now the motion before us is ought
to pass as amended I will show it as
papichi and Murray yes Mr chair I'd like
to make the motion to UT to pass as
amended for Bill 10 1304 FN as just
amended thank you further discussion on
the motion of ought to pass as amended
on House Bill
1304 seeing none are you ready for the
question if you're in favor you'll say I
if you oppose no on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill
1304 very good representative F
yes represent McGuire I represent Petri
votes yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin
yes representative Lon yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes Representative
hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative camell
yes represent papichi Muller yes
represent walner
yes represent Lehman
yes represent buo yes represent of VT
yes resident of Heath yes repr of Murray
yes res evil
yes represent
tki yes represent hen Phillips
yes represent Stringham
yes representative grassy yes
representative priest
yes representative uh wer
yes um Mr chair the vote is 24 to
one in favor of the motion and the a to
passes amended is adopted 24 to1 will
there be a Minority Report no minority
okay
and lurb is by representative
papichi represent Emer okay thank you Mr
chairman House Bill 1330 FN relative to
establishing an emergency medical
services disciplinary review panel and
Rel to procedures for removal of records
of discipline I would look to
representative Petri for a
motion representative
Petri yeah thank you Mr chairman uh I
move a to pass on house is it 1330 1330
okay this wasn't my bill but that's all
right got to figure out where I'm at if
I
may I would like to make the OTP motion
for Bill HB
1330 and briefly speak to my motion you
recognize to speak to your motion of our
to pass thank you this is a bill that um
came out of committee on a split vote
because the committee had a concern
about the needed Amendment the amendment
was brought to the floor of the house
and this passed on a Voice vote uh it's
a very good bill that creates parity for
the EMTs by giving them the same type of
Protections in terms of handling any
disciplinary proceedings that all the
other similarly regulated process Pro
um professions have and uh it had no
position u in finance to it was a 90
vote it's a well- written bill that I
feel we should
pass is there a number to the
amendment the amendment was already
adopted on the floor so we are adopting
we are just voting uh on the bill as
currently is as voted by the house all
right so the motion is simply ought to
pass Is there further discussion on the
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
1330 seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call a role
ought to pass on House Bill
1330 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative
Leon representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
POA vich meller
yes represent
walner yes
representative Lehman yes representative
buo yes representative huitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative eel yes
representative torski yes I'm
sorry yes thank
you represent haken Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent grassy
yes represent priest yes representative
wer yes Mr chairman the vote is 25
deserving the
affirmative
okay now this has does this have any
money in
it what is this 30 something, I'm being
informed by my colleague all right let's
try putting that on the regular calendar
regular or I mean no consent okay when
our report no and papichi will write the
report
okay P right okay representative
emmer thank you Mr
chairman uh House Bill 1339 FN relative
to background checks during months to
return firearms and ammunition on this
one I'll look to representative Petri
sorry about that last time not a problem
thank you um yeah this bill basically uh
sets up due process for uh Turing of
firearms uh as reference uh uh the
proceedings in the
court and basically uh it looks to the
Department of Safety to do a nck
check and if the if it's approve if it's
uh what they say proceed then nothing
happens it uh the individual gets his
firearms and or ammunition
back if it denied then a certain process
the individual has a right within 10
days to
uh call for a
hearing at the hearing all right uh they
have uh the court has 10 days
to uh schedule that hearing department
of safety at that hearing needs to
um e they they have to be
there and and they have to defend their
position with uh convincing clear and
convincing
evidence and if it's not then uh
obviously the uh the individual gets his
uh items
back
if if for some reason the hearing uh
goes negatively then that can be
appealed to the uh state supreme court
without cost to the individual our our
uh Endeavor this is going to be about
$70,000 per year there's nothing in the
fiscal note it doesn't approve any more
positions and uh the money is very
insignificant it uh they there's no
appropriation for this uh this endeavor
in the fiscal note thank
you who made the second uh that's a good
question uh all right is there a second
from division two second okay thank you
right all
right motion and second
to pass ought to pass as House Bill
1339 is there any further
discussion represent hu your lights on
did you have any to say seeing none all
right clerk will call a rooll on the
motion of a to pass on House Bill
1339 all right thank you Mr chairman uh
let me see representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Leon yes
representative uh Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney
yes resent cimal yes pres papovich
Muller yes representative walner yes
representative leean yes representative
buo yes representative uitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative torki yes representative
haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham
yes representative grassy
yes representative priest yes
representa wer yes Mr chair the vote is
25 to Zer in the
affirmative is this one with much money
in it no this is no money well it's it's
nothing nothing appropriated it's just
uh 68 to 73,000 per year well it's it's
not really 73,000 per year on average on
average all right we'll put this on the
regular calendar on consent is that what
you're saying no regular this 7 I'm
trying I'm trying I
know
P okay there is no minority
majority
Ready House Bill 1466 FN relative to
providing disaster relief funding to
municipalities after a natural disaster
I recognize representative Heath for a
motion thank you Mr division 2 chair I
would like to move um House Bill 1466
are to
pass is there a
second second second by represent
Emme and if I may please discussion
representative Heath I would like to
point out the fact that this is a very
rare event in a
bill the chair and I are both
co-sponsors you will not see that very
often it's up to
[Laughter]
you house bill
1466 is a bipartisan Bill and it
authorizes disaster relief of
municipalities that have suffered
certain natural disasters and EST and
establishes a Recovery Fund um that a a
municipality uh can actually go to it
authorizes the municipality to be able
to go to the fiscal committee to present
the petition um for up to $100,000 and
then the fiscal committee would make the
decision of how much they could get and
that's only for um one they can only
come forward one time in a year the
purpose of the emergency response and
Recovery Fund is to provide immediate uh
liquidity for towns suffering a disaster
to allow time for the town to go through
the steps NE necessary to petition the
steps necessary for further um Homeland
Security or FEMA funding uh it is the
intent that this grant will be
reimbursable from state or federal
disaster relief fund request shall be
filed with the joint fiscal committee
within 45 days and will coordinate with
the federal management a agency the fund
shall be non-aps um and continually
appropriated to the Department of sa
safety
I think we all um realize the weather is
changing and that so many small
communities are severely impacted and
this was a bill that that was
unanimously approved in division two and
I'd ask for your support for of OT pass
OTP please is there any further
discussion on House Bill 13 oh
correction 1466 seeing none the clerk
will call the role on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill
1466 thank you Mr
chairman representative F yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri vs yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griff Griffin
yes representative Leon yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative
caml yes representa Popich Muller yes
representative walner
yes representative leichman yes
representative buo yes representative
huitt yes representative Heath
yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
torski
yes representative hen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassy
yes represent priest yes represent W yes
Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z any
affirmative okay I guess we'll put this
on the regular calendar because it does
spend
100,000 shows no money per
year I think there's money a lot of
money it it stipulates that a town can
request up to $100,000 it doesn't
appropriate anything but a fund will
have to be
established yeah I believe Mickey yeah I
think this has money is that correct it
definitely money 100 pounds
it's so if the folks in division 2 will
recall this bill allows the
municipalities to seek uh funding with
fiscal approval from those dis that
Disaster Relief Fund which has $45,000
in it there's no other mechanism here so
I'd say this bill somewhat limited to
that so you can decide if that's the
threshold for consent or regular that
we'll put it on the regular calendar and
especially where it's 25 to Zer I don't
think we're going to have much
discussion thank you very
much and the report will be written by
representative
Heath representative Emer okay thank you
and I'd like to thank the efforts of
division two even though we get a little
testy with each other sometimes we along
pretty
well HB 1468 FNA directing the
Department of Transportation to develop
a Conway Branch rail line master plan I
Look to representative Buco for
motion thank you Mr
chairman
um this is this uh this I I move ought
to pass on House Bill
1468 second Motion in a second of ought
1468 representative Buco is recognized
thank you Mr
chairman this bill directs the
Department of Transportation to work
with the Bureau of rails and Transit and
the Bureau of trails and also meet with
the executive counselor in District 1 me
uh a member of the House Public Works
and highways committee a member of the
Senate capital budget committee and a
representative of the North Coast
Railroad
to formulate a master plan for the best
public use of the Conway branch which is
about a 10 Mile Rail corridor from oapi
to
Madison the master plan uh shall explore
the uses and costs of bringing the rail
carrier to a safe level uh surface for
recreational
activity and since the uh Finance the
the fiscal
note says that the fiscal impact would
be less than
$10,000 and so I I move ought to
pass okay motion of V to pass on House
Bill 1468 by representative puko is
there any further discussion
representative Maguire thank you I'd
like to ask a question um I've taken the
train in Conway before is this the same
track or different track
or I don't know what train you took into
Conway but there's not one that runs all
the way from
oi to Conway did no I got on in Conway
right there there's there's a um there's
a Scenic Railroad the Conway Conway
Scenic
Railroad but it doesn't go down this far
I see so this is more for is is this an
extension of that or is this completely
different or yes it would be completely
different it's not has nothing to do
with Conway
Conway North Conway Scenic Railroad
is goes It goes from con North Conway
back to Conway and then back that's
that's the I think there there's one
that leaves the station there in um wiip
pasak where the Mount Washington is is
that was that where the Conway Scenic
Railroad goes Representative no con
Conway Scenic Railroad goes from North
Conway to back to Conway South and then
back to North Conway it also goes out
north to to to
Bartlet but but but this this Branch
here goes from oopy to Madison and it's
been not has not been used for many
years oh all right so what what this
what this bill would do would put put
these people together to um come up with
some kind of a master plan what we heard
in testimony was really they just want
to get it to the point where it's safe
and level and
and you know and not not do anything
else with with it at this time thank you
representative Mari yeah I just wanted
to clarify this is um a feasibility
study regarding the snowmobiling walking
and biking on an existing Trail this
becomes a rail trail it's not about the
train it's about the rail trail and
people's public use for it thank you
representative
Edwards uh representative Murray may
have just answered my question but I I I
would assume that the do already has
authority to do strateg IC planning and
already has a budget for senior managers
who are supposed to be good at strategic
planning and so I I just need to ask the
question you know why do we have to
legislate something the executive branch
ought to just do because they're
professionals my understanding if I may
um thank thank you um the
trail goes across several municipalities
and areas and this is a way of bringing
people from the disparate areas together
and I I guess it requires a little bit
of effort or
perhaps um recognition that it's okay
for them to come together and and talk
about
this if it passes the legislature then
we've kind of instructed do to get busy
on this maybe they've been ignoring
it just a
thought so further
discussion seeing none the cler will
call the role on the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill
1468 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire
no representative Petri is thinking
about
it got two seconds
yeah now what the hell
yes representative Emer
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Lon
yes representative
Edwards reluctantly
yes representative Bean yes
Representative hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative camell
yes representative papovich Muller yes
Presa
walner
yes
representative Lehman
yes representative buo yes
obviously representative huitt
yes representative Heath
yes representative Murray
yes representative evil yes
representative torki
yes representative hen Phillips
yes yes geez a good thing you're shaking
your head cuz I cannot doesn't sound
like a yes but that's okay
representative Stringham yes that's a
good one there I know that one
representative grassy
yes representative priest
yes 22 and representative
yes Mr chair the vote uh chairman the
vote is
23-2 will there be a Minority
Report no who's the majority
that motion was representative bu and
for your information we just ran out of
bills yes congratulations for all the
work yes we still need minority reports
for 1199 and 1394 we need to know the
authors of the minority reports on 1199
and 1394
1394 uh if you're going to if you don't
have them in by by the time we today
they won't get in the bud they won't get
in the calendar send you to P County
that's what we'll do and if you made a
motion uh on any of these bills please
before you leave today I have to have
the blur according to what the speaker
says
and if you had a vote like 25 to zero
you probably won't have to speak if you
had a split vote and you made the motion
you will probably have to speak on the
bill and
at least have a have a uh a pi and I
will discuss with the two division heads
who will do the pis on the split votes
and either either the uh division chairs
or I will make the
piis on those on those things so if you
if you made a motion on a split vote be
ready for discussion and have a have a
realization that I will give be giving
you name to the clerk when he wants to
call on someone to speak so you believe
and if say
again representative Edwards uh thank
thank you Mr chair I for um a division
three update I I just want to point out
that we had nine bills uh we're pretty
set on on at least half of them we're
meeting again Friday where we're going
to make a disposition recommendation on
on all of them um a couple of them we're
going to take another look at one of
them being representative tersi uh HB
1595 uh I understand you want to make a
interim study recommendation there'll be
an opportunity uh Friday to do that uh
it's an 7 to2 otpa at this point but uh
I think you have good cause to uh have
us relook it so so we're making progress
I I I don't think we're going to be
causing the committee to be late thank
you thank you very much representative
bman um you're all set tomorrow for a u
division one meeting have several bills
there
10:00 and I think representative McGuire
has put out a
caucus bid for the Republicans already
at
9:15 so uh without any further
uh anything further
no before we go
I thank you all for your good work and
uh as I said if you've made a motion and
it was a split vote be ready for the uh
for the speech if uh if not you probably
don't have anything to worry about even
though it's likely to be on the regular
calendar if it spends money but I
suspect the speaker will just move
through those very quickly with voice
votes
so the finance committee is adjourned
thank you all very much for all your
good work oh yeah and your
attendance